[Applause]
[Music]
happy friday my frighteningly friendly
little freaks
it's the last day of halloween week
which means it's time to check in on our
favorite sitcom
previously on here's greg ah
would you look at this
i've seen it a million times
another miniature red plastic car
running over a co-worker after being
driven recklessly by a tiny grey gut
fell dummy
you know it never gets any easier
what the hell
[Music]
tonight's episode justice comes calling
hi thank you so much for coming in oh
i'm vaccinated you don't have to wear
her mask
so it has come to my attention that you
may have murdered emily compagno
that is obviously very against company
policy so what do you have to say for
yourself
take your silence to mean that you're
denying the allegations but you have an
extreme amount of facial wounds
so it's pretty clear that you were
involved in a vehicular incident i'm
afraid i'm going to have to let you go
candy
just in time for halloween
that's so sweet you know what
forget about the whole year fired thing
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
the show has allowed me to kill both
emily companio and cat tim
so another day in new york city means
another woman brutally beaten on a
subway train it's becoming as routine as
death and taxes which could be the
slogan for biden in 2024
so this video made the rounds and it's
brutal but it's not really surprising
to my facebook
head to my face now tell me to take a
chill pill all right
so far this video is closing in on three
million views 1 million likely by me
i've watched it more times than the
outtakes from naked and afraid
because like the planet fitness steam
room after 8 pm there's a lot going on
in that packed train
obviously this video shows a crazed dude
slugging a chick in the face after she
tells him to take a chill pill
now maybe i'm wrong but punching someone
who tells you to take a chill pill is
the worst way to prove that you don't
need a chill
it happened on the d train which
apparently stands for dangerous or
deadly or damn why am i still living in
new york city god please help me get the
out of here
it's amazing
getting worse
every day it's getting worse now the man
had been shouting say it to my face
regarding her chill pill comment which
she does and for what it's worth that
shows a tremendous amount of bravery or
stupidity
mind your business he says it again and
then he says i'm dealing with my effing
kids whom i'm sure will grow up normal
having that for a dad
hopefully child protective services
notices what a great father he really is
so he smacks her hard and no one did a
damn thing to intervene or check on the
woman or subdue the perp
chivalry is dead and it probably got
killed by a guy with a long rap sheet
who was led out of jail by democrats
no wonder far left politicians are
hiring all those security guards which
means it's time for
wwy
d-i-t-s-a-s-b-h-o yes it's time for what
would you do in this situation and
seriously be honest okay
because when i watched this i became
enraged at the bystanders who after
appearing shocked
seemed to do nothing except to look at
their phones and avoid void eye contact
they act like me when kill me talks
about his phlebitis
i don't even know what that is
hope it's nothing serious
now this is the second such story where
people witness a horrible crime and do
nothing in philly recently an
incapacitated woman was allegedly raped
by an illegal alien sex fiend on a
subway train and no one did anything but
as i keep thinking about this i wonder
what would i have done i'd like to think
i would have rushed to the woman's age
scolded the guy and if he lunged at me i
would have clocked him sending him
writhing to the floor
but let's be honest as guys we replay
these heroic fantasies in our heads
it's one of many some fantasize catching
the winning pass at the super bowl i
fantasize about rescuing a child from a
well
which isn't that helpful since in the
fantasy i also threw him down the well
but reality sets in
maybe on the subway i would have done
nothing
here's why a man who slugs a woman sends
a message that he'd do anything chivalry
is dead because bystanders know if they
step in they'll be dead too
and then of course he created a force
field by claiming he was a victim of
racism the sad part is because this is
nyc half the people on the train
probably agreed with him and if a white
man stepped in the story would become
about race and all those folks who just
looked down at their phones would be
sure to point the phone at the melee and
we would view that clip thousands of
times but with the context of a black
man accosted by a white guy on a train
accusations of race keep everyone in
their place everything is judged not by
context but by group identity just like
mlk didn't dream about
remember a cop prevented a fatal
stabbing of a black woman only to be
called out by lebron james if you dare
address bad behavior anywhere it's you
who becomes the oppressor
doesn't matter that the crime was
riddled with sexism because a strong man
was pounding on a young woman women are
equal to men now remember she should
expect to get clocked just as hard as a
man would don't step in man the
independent woman can do it alone it's a
sad state of affairs and danger is the
only mistress the fact is our world
doesn't get worse overnight it sneaks up
on you like male pattern baldness
robbie
without reacting
without reacting we let it unfold when
our heads are down crime goes up it
started with the soft bigotry of low
expectations followed by the notion that
cops and prosecutors are part of the
problem finally criminals are let loose
and there's nothing we can do about it
but capture their crimes on our phones
perhaps fresh after 9 11 the spirit of
unity would have crushed this perp but
now in this strange new world we've
lowered the bar for behavior it went
from a low bar to no bar to headlines
like man or woman beat to death in a bar
leaving society fubar
but hey maybe someone should have called
a social worker
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest
his jimmy neutron costume wouldn't even
need a wig reason senior editor robbie
suave
you know he's in the building when the
hobos show up demanding their clothes
back box across america host jimmy
failure
unlike the three-month-old yogurt in
catspurse she makes the kind of films we
love to see
director and former white house staffer
amanda milius
and she turns heads when she walks into
a building because of the loud sound it
makes as she hits the wall
fox news contributor
so jimmy the only thing worse than that
woman getting hit by that guy is the
current jacket that you're wearing
i mean that isn't a that is punching me
in the eyeballs
i keep forgetting you've landed a role
as a villain in the new fashion movie
the devil wears oshkosh
oh i think the villain is whoever sold
that to you
i love that you think i paid for this
and if anyone is interested yes it does
come in men's
are we um what is this a disturbing sign
of society or is this just how people
act in a packed subway so they don't get
hit yeah well that's part of it i mean
that's why guys didn't jump in and i
have mixed emotions on this because i
spend a lot of money on craigslist to
get beat up you know so
there is that element to this
there is that element to the story
but can we just acknowledge that at no
point during this attack was anyone on
the train saying man it's a good thing
there's not an unvaccinated cop coming
here
because that would make everything
terrible right exactly it's so insane
and the reality here is um because it is
a black man hitting a white woman this
story is not a story like if you're not
shining a light on it it's not really
getting talked about right because it
goes against that narrative that you
know white people are evil and we have
what you know we have it coming to us
which i think is so cheap and stupid and
i think this is a reality that
politicians have created that they
themselves don't live in and i think
even getting beyond race we're going to
see more of this just because the subway
is what a constant reminder that things
aren't going well for you in life you
know what i mean you're stuck on the
subway
have you ever had one of those moments
because everybody's mad everybody is the
worst version of themselves on the
subway if you ever one of those moments
where you run the catch the train i mean
you run and like ready to get there the
door shut right in front of your face
you're like god i hope that train blows
up
but then a second later
i never felt that way
you don't take the train but then but
then a second later the doors reopen and
now you're on the train yeah
i don't know if this was the best idea
you know i felt that way when i was
watching sliding doors yeah
[Laughter]
a call back to a 1996 film starring
gwyneth paltrow what is wrong with you
people she missed the sliding doors and
then enjoy life changes and then she
dies
i like that part amanda let's talk about
movies your dad death wish right
no wait what movie what movie that my
dad did yeah death wish red dawn conan
the barbarian and um he wrote apocalypse
now which is a little different than
deathwing why do i always tie your dad
john milius to deathwish because it's
his persona it's like very larger than
life and kind of thank you for saving me
but that's worrying
yes so apocalypse now
sure are we at the apocalypse now
[Laughter]
thank you
[Laughter]
good everybody i saved it
well i saved it amanda no but um
to jimmy's point it's like
uh if you're scared of being called a
racist you're not gonna do anything yeah
i mean a lot of people were talking
about this story like it had to do with
crime where they were saying things like
well democrats voted for this it's new
york city this is the kind of crime that
you know happens when you let people out
of jail and have loose crime laws and
you're like no it's actually about race
like if this was a white guy that
punched this woman like people would not
have hesitated as much to step in
um i also think it's really weird
because i mean yeah as you said like
nobody wants to be the karen on the
viral video and that's what they've
created um and that's that's gonna get
much worse the other thing that's crazy
is i heard that the guy that's standing
next to her was her boyfriend no
i don't know if that's true or not but
like i don't know how you continue
having yeah if it's true anymore
yeah like how do you continue to have
like a normal relationship with a man
that doesn't step in in that situation
that's bananas well we don't know we
don't know that but let's pretend it is
true because that's what we're doing
okay no problem i'm not free i'll give
you like the unverified yes
yes the unfair radio was her boyfriend
and uh yes they're not sleeping together
anymore no problem yes all right robbie
as i said in my monologue every guy
thinks that they're going to do
something right i'm sure you've had
these fantasies on your little electric
scooter
i'm going to write about it later
really bold action i will take
journalists no big deal
i know
but you know i think um i don't know how
new this kind of stuff is it's now we're
recording it on video now everyone all
the time has their phone out they see
something they gotta let you see 30
seconds of it now what happened before
not what happens after true and we all
form impressions and we're talking about
it on tv which is what everybody does
but uh i don't i don't know how how new
it is it is new to like hear about crime
or hear about like in dc when they're
shooting someone's murdered and then you
wait and they go okay and they weren't
socially distancing oh yes oh no yeah
that's the you know that's what's
alarmed yeah that subway was packed by
the way
some of those people dead did get
covered cat well listen kovin's like the
best thing to catch on the subway if
we're being honest
it's the safest thing to catch actually
i've caught some things there and
they've taken it home with me
no cat what lessons were there lessons
learned
um i guess it depends very rarely ever
are there lessons
i i i guess you know new york we keep
talking about this it's getting it's
awful stuff like this happens all the
time but it's also so expensive still
yes to be here and that's upsetting to
me because i really want to know like
what
what am i paying for you know like not
and i don't mean that in a rhetorical
sense but truly like what am i paying
for it's not safe there's garbage
everywhere and yeah stuff like that
happens and if it wasn't for a ticked we
would never know about it because i'm
sure that's happened again since that
video was made something like that
probably five more times yeah there's a
guy outside my building who punches the
mailbox yeah well what are the mail i
prefer what did the mailbox do to him
though exactly either well the mailbox
said chill pill yeah
yeah one time a guy broke up with me for
not being chill which was not a very
chill thing of him to do that is true
that is but then you killed him yes
laughing now yes hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else